[Music]
I'm a hundred and fifty feet down an
illegal mineshaft in Ghana the air is
thick with heat and dust and it's hard
to breathe
I can feel the brush of sweaty bodies
passing me in the darkness but I can't
see much else I hear voices talking but
mostly the shaft is this cacophony of
men coughing and stone being broken with
primitive tools like the others
I wear a flickering cheap flashlight
tied to my head with this elastic
tattered band and I can barely make out
the slit tree limbs holding up the walls
of the three-foot square hole dropping
hundreds of feet into the earth when my
hand slips I suddenly remember a miner I
had met days before who had lost his
grip and felt countless feet down that
shaft as I stand talking to you today
these men are still deep in that hole
risking their lives without payment or
compensation and often dying I got to
climb out of that hole
and I got to go home but they likely
never will because they're trapped in
slavery for the last 28 years I've been
documenting indigenous cultures in more
than 70 countries on six continents and
in 2009 I had the great honor of being
the sole exhibitor at the Vancouver
peace summit amongst all the astonishing
people I met there I met a supporter of
free the slaves an NGO dedicated to
eradicating modern-day slavery we
started talking about slavery and really
I started learning about slavery fried
certainly known it existed in the world
but not to such a degree after we
finished talk
I felt so horrible and honestly ashamed
at my own lack of knowledge of this
atrocity in my own lifetime and I
thought if I don't know how many other
people don't know it started burning a
hole in my stomach so within weeks I
flew down to Los Angeles to meet with
the director of free the slaves and
offer them my help
thus began my journey into modern-day
slavery
oddly I have been to many of these
places before some I even considered
like my second home but this time I
would see the skeletons hidden in the
closet a conservative estimate tells us
there are more than 27 million people
enslaved in the world today that's
double the amount of people taken from
Africa during the entire transatlantic
slave trade a hundred and fifty years
ago an agricultural slave cost about
three times the annual salary of an
American worker that equates to about
$50,000 in today's money yet today
entire families can be enslaved for
generations over a debt as small as $18
astonishingly slavery generates profits
of more than 13 billion dollars
worldwide each year many have been
tricked by false promises of a good
education a better job only to find that
they're forced to work without pay under
the threat of violence and they cannot
walk away
today's slavery is about commerce so the
goods that enslaved people produce have
value but the people producing them are
disposable slavery exists everywhere
nearly in the world and yet it is
illegal everywhere in the world
in India and Nepal I was introduced to
the brick kilns the strange and awesome
sight was like walking into ancient
Egypt or Dante's Inferno enveloped in
temperatures of a hundred and thirty
degrees men women children
entire families in fact were cloaked in
a heavy blanket of dust while
mechanically stacking bricks on their
head up to 18 at a time and carrying
them from the scorching kilns to trucks
hundreds of yards away deadened by
monotony and exhaustion they work
silently doing this task over and over
for 16 or 17 hours a day there were no
breaks for food no water breaks and the
severe dehydration made urinating pretty
much inconsequential so pervasive was
the heat and the dust that my camera
became too hot to even touch and ceased
working every twenty minutes I'd have to
run back to our Cruiser to clean out my
gear and run it under an air-conditioner
to revive it and as I sat there i
thought my camera is getting far better
treatment than these people back in the
kilns I wanted to cry but the
abolitionist next to me quickly grabbed
me and he said Lisa don't do that just
don't do that here and he very clearly
explained to me that emotional displays
are very dangerous in a place like this
not just for me but for them I couldn't
offer them any direct help I couldn't
give them money nothing I wasn't a
citizen of that country I could get them
in a worse situation than they were
already in I'd have to rely on free the
slaves to work within the system for
their liberation and I trusted that they
would as for me I'd have to wait until I
got home to really feel my heartbreak
in the Himalayas I found children
carrying stone from miles down
mountainous terrain to trucks waiting at
roads below the big sheets of slate were
heavier than the children carrying them
and the kids hoisted them from their
heads using these handmade harnesses of
sticks and rope and torn cloth it's
difficult to witness something so
overwhelming how can we affect something
so insidious yet so pervasive some don't
even know they're enslaved people
working 16 17 hours a day without any
pay because this has been the case all
their lives they have nothing to compare
it to when these villagers claimed their
freedom the slaveholders burned down all
of their houses I mean these people had
nothing and they were so petrified they
wanted to give up but the woman in the
center rallied for them to persevere and
abolitionists on the ground helped them
get a core release of their own so that
now they'd do the same back-breaking
work but they do it for themselves and
they get paid for it and they do it in
freedom sex trafficking is what we often
think of when we hear the word slavery
and because of this worldwide awareness
I was warned that it would be difficult
for me to work safely within this
particular industry and Katmandu I was
escorted by women who had previously
been sex slaves themselves they ushered
me down a narrow set of stairs that led
to this dirty dimly fluorescent-lit
basement this wasn't a brothel per se it
was more like a restaurant cabin
restaurants as they're known in the
trade are venues for forced prostitution
each has small private rooms where the
slaves women along with young girls and
boys some as young as seven years old
are forced to entertain the clients
encouraging them to buy more food
and alcohol each cubicle is dark and
dingy identified with a painted number
on the wall and partitioned by plywood
and a curtain the workers here often
endure tragic sexual abuse at the hands
of their customers standing in the near
darkness
I remember feeling this quick hot fear
and in that instant I could only imagine
what it must be like to be trapped in
that hell I had only one way out the
stairs from where I'd come in there were
no back doors there were no windows
large enough to climb through these
people have no escape at all and as we
take in such a difficult subject it's
important to note that slavery including
sex trafficking occurs in our own
backyard as well tens of hundreds of
people are enslaved in agriculture in
restaurants in domestic servitude and
the list can go on recently the New York
Times reported that between 100,000 and
300,000 American children are sold into
sex slavery every year it's all around
us we just don't see it the textile
industry is another one we often think
of when we hear about slave labor I
visited villages in India where entire
families were enslaved in this silk
trade this is a family portrait the dyed
black hands are the father while the
blue and red hands are his sons they mix
dye in these big barrels and they
submerge the silk into the liquid up to
their elbows but the dye is toxic my
interpreter told me their stories we
have no freedom they said we hope still
though that we could leave this house
someday and go someplace else where we
actually get paid for our
it's estimated that more than 4,000
children are enslaved on Lake Volta the
largest man-made lake in the world when
we first arrived I went to have a quick
look I saw what seemed to be a family
fishing on a boat two older brothers
some younger kids make sense right wrong
they were all enslaved children are
taken from their families and trafficked
and vanished and they're forced to work
endless hours on these boats on the lake
even though they do not know how to swim
this young child is 8 years old he was
trembling when our boat approached
frightened it would run over his tiny
canoe he was petrified he would be
knocked in the water the skeletal tree
limbs submerged in Lake Volta often
catch the fishing nets and weary
frightened children are thrown into the
water to untether the lines many of them
drown for as long as he can recall he's
been forced to work on the lake
terrified of his master he will not run
away and since he's been treated with
cruelty all his life he passes that down
to the younger slaves that he manages I
met these boys at 5:00 in the morning
when they were hauling in the last of
their nets but they had been working
since 1:00 a.m. in the cold windy night
and it's important to note that these
nets weigh more than a thousand pounds
when they're full of fish I want to
introduce you to Kofi Kofi was rescued
from a fishing village I met him at a
shelter where free the slaves
rehabilitates victims of slavery here
he's seen taking a bath at the well
pouring big buckets of water over his
head and the wonderful news is as you
and I are sitting here talking today
Kofi has been reunited with his
family and what's even better his family
has been given tools to make a living
and to keep their children safe Kofi is
the embodiment of possibility who will
he become because someone took a stand
and made a difference in his life
driving down a road in Ghana with
partners of free the slaves
a fellow abolitionists on a moped
suddenly sped up to our Cruiser and
tapped on the window he told us to
follow him down a dirt road into the
jungle at the end of the road he urged
us out of the car and told the driver to
quickly leave then he pointed toward
this barely visible footpath and he said
this is the path this is a path go as we
started down the path we pushed aside
the vines blocking the way and after
about a walk an hour of walking in found
that the trail had become flooded by
recent rains so I hosted the photo gear
above my head as we descended into these
waters up to my chest after another two
hours of hiking the windy trail abruptly
ended at a clearing and before us was a
mass of holes that could fit into the
size of a football field and all of them
were full of enslaved people laboring
many women had children strapped to
their backs while they were panning for
gold wading in water poisoned by mercury
mercury is used in the extraction
process these miners are enslaved in a
mine shaft in another part of Ghana when
they came out of the shaft they were
soaking wet from their own sweat I
remember looking into their tired
bloodshot eyes for many of them had been
underground for 72 hours the shafts are
up to 300 feet deep and they carry out
heavy bags of stones
that later will be transported to
another area where the stone will be
pounded so that they can extract the
gold at first glance the pounding site
seems full of powerful men but when we
look closer we see some less fortunate
working on the fringes and children too
all of them are victim to injury illness
and violence in fact it's very likely
that this muscular person will end up
like this one here wracked with
tuberculosis and mercury poisoning in
just a few years this is my new room
when his father died his uncle
trafficked him to work with him in the
mines when his uncle died manure
inherited his uncle's dead which further
forced him into being enslaved in the
mines when I met him he had been working
in the mines for 14 years and the leg
injury that you see here is actually
from a mining accident one so severe
doctors say his leg should be amputated
on top of that Munro has tuberculosis
yet he's still forced to work day in and
day out in that mine shaft even still he
has a dream that he will become free and
become educated with the help of local
activists like free the slaves and it's
this sort of determination in the face
of unimaginable odds that fills me with
complete awe
I want to shine a light on slavery when
I was working in the field I brought
lots of candles with me and with the
help of my interpreter I imparted to the
people I was photographing that I wanted
to illuminate their stories and their
plight so when it was safe for them and
safe for me
I made these images they knew their
image would be seen by you out in the
world I wanted them to know that we will
be bearing witness to them and that we
will do whatever we can to help make a
difference in their lives
I truly believe if we can see one
another as fellow human beings then it
becomes very difficult to tolerate
atrocities like slavery these images are
not of issues they are of people real
people like you and me all deserving of
the same rights dignity and respect in
their lives there is not a day that goes
by that I don't think of these many
beautiful mistreated people I've had the
tremendous honor of meeting I hope that
these images awaken a force in those who
view them people like you and I hope
that force will ignite a fire and that
fire will shine a light on slavery for
without that light the beasts of bondage
can continue to live in the shadows
thank you very much
[Applause]
you